[Music]  bachelor Winter Games stars Claire and  Benoit call off their engagement Claire  announced their split on Instagram  Thursday writing quote it's with a heavy  heart that we have mutually decided to  end our relationship we think the world  of each other and we were both hoping we  could make this work  their romance has had a unique story  they met on winter games but didn't  start dating till after the show stopped  filming Benoit pulled off a surprise  proposal during the reunion special  [Music]  [Applause]  et was backstage right after the big  moment I think we're balancing each  other this is the best thing about the  two of us is definitely like we can  really understand where each other like  we're coming from I love him for him and  his weirdnesses and nuances and my  weirdness is my nuances  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]